hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
apparently a lot of people care about
this iphone 6 sapphire crystal display
so in that video that i did about it i
went through a couple tests to measure
the durability of the panel i bent it a
lot i put it under my foot and pulled on
it really hard i dragged my keys and my
knife across it and then eventually
stabbed it pretty hard but i was never
able to get it to scratch but here's the
thing about scratch tests with knives
and keys
knives and keys aren't that
hard they're i mean they're pretty sharp
obviously on the end if i drag it across
my own skin it'll hurt a lot but when
you compare it to sapphire glass or
really any glass for that matter gorilla
glass included metal is pretty soft so
let me introduce you to the mohs scale
it's a scale from 1 to 10 rating mineral
hardness so basically how it works is at
any rating
a mineral can scratch anything below it
but cannot scratch anything above it so
take quartz for example on that scale
it's rated at a seven that means
anything above a seven can be used to
cut quartz but anything below it won't
even make a mark so on the mohs scale my
steel knife blade that i use in that
video is a 5.5 gorilla glass is already
at a 6.8 and pure sapphire which is a
form of aluminum oxide is the second
hardest naturally occurring material on
earth it's at a 9. so by those numbers a
steel knife blade no matter how hard i
try will never scratch my phone's
display gorilla glass or sapphire so
let's say goodbye to knifeblade scratch
tests this new test is pretty legit
welcome to the era of sandpaper screen
tests because every smartphone on the
market right now should survive the
softer metals from your knife or keys so
i have two types of sandpaper here the
first one is garnet it's a bit softer
it's at about a seven on the mohs scale
which means it's harder than gorilla
glass but softer than pure sapphire and
the second is emery it's at about an
eight a little higher than eight on the
mohs scale so it'll really be able to
show we're working with here now keep in
mind we already know exactly what we're
working with on the front of the iphone
5s it's gorilla glass 3 on the front
like in some other phones but the home
button that small little part is already
sapphire apple chose that part because
it's small not too expensive and it can
resist scratches better than gorilla
glass to keep that touch id fingerprint
stuff working even when the phone gets
beat up so the new iphone 6 has this
entire display made of a new material
that we already know can bend really
well but sandpaper will show its true
hardness so the first piece of garnet
sandpaper take it to the gorilla glass
of the iphone 5s it immediately
scratched a lot and that's expected it's
a harder material so this is exactly
what should happen picking the same
material to the iphone 6 screen with the
same force it actually does scratch as
well
but not quite as much it does resist
those scratches a little better and i
also noticed it made a very different
sound when scratching
so we're learning here that already this
new display is definitely not pure
sapphire because it's already getting
scratched by a softer garnet so what's
interesting is check out the iphone 5s
home button it's still flawless not a
single scratch the garnet did not
scratch the theoretically much closer to
pure sapphire home button which actually
means the home button was damaging the
garnet okay so moving on to the emery
much harder sandpaper taking it to the
iphone 5s no real surprise here it
basically destroys it puts some really
deep scratches all over the panel pretty
much instantaneously so that gorilla
glass is much softer didn't stand a
chance
taking it to the iphone 6 display now we
of course still get scratching it again
made a different sound and it is much
more limited so this material is
definitely harder it holds up better to
the much more tough emery sandpaper but
it's definitely not indestructible or
invincible and for good measure i
actually went back over the pure
sapphire of the iphone 5s home button
again and it held up still really really
well so i'm impressed with the pure
sapphire of course it shouldn't scratch
because it's harder than the sandpapers
we used so what do we learned from all
this testing two things number one the
iphone 6 display is harder than gorilla
glass and will put up to scratching and
bending a lot better than the iphone 5s
display did and two the iphone 6 display
is not pure sapphire like the touch id
home button is and that actually makes
sense using a massive panel of pure
sapphire for the front of a phone would
be a little bit stupid it would be first
of all much more expensive and it also
wouldn't be able to bend like it did
believe it or not you actually kind of
need your phone to be able to flex a
little bit so pure sapphire is still
best in smaller parts like the touch id
cover over the home button and the glass
over the back of the iphone 5s camera a
little bit of research shows that
apple's actually already patented a
fusion process where the sapphire
structure may also be mechanically
modified to help reduce the likelihood
of chipping or fracturing and the
resulting sapphire laminate may achieve
both superior hardness and strength due
to the use of multiple planes basically
it's a composite involving sapphire to
make it overall a lot stronger than the
gorilla glass of the previous iphones or
many other phones out there and it works
as we saw and i'll have the link to the
exact pattern right below the like
button if you want to check that out but
basically as long as you're not carrying
some high quality sandpaper in your
pocket you should be good without a
screen protector on the next iphone
which is really comforting for a lot of
people to hear and i'm sure apple will
talk a lot i would expect a lot of talk
from apple at their next keynote about
how strong and indestructible this
material is well
not really indestructible
you